Hey folks, it's Strixhaven season. I
asked my patrons which of the new
precons I should review, and Lorehold
narrowly beat out Silverquill to be the
top result. So, what's going on with
Lorehold? I'll get into the details
later, but to start with I'll say that
this is definitely one of the weaker
precons I've reviewed. That's not
necessarily saying a lot since I've only
reviewed seven total, and the last two
were quite excellent precons, but it
does make for a fun deviation from a lot
of the more powerful precons we've been
seeing lately.
Before I get into this precon's key
issues and how we can go about solving
them, let's give a quick rundown on this
deck's game plan. The face commander is
Quintorius, History Chaser. This is a
four-mana planeswalker with the passive
ability, whenever one or more cards
leave your graveyard, create a 3/2 red
and white spirit creature token. His
plus one ability reads, you may discard
a card. If you do, draw two cards, then
mill a card. His minus four ability
reads, spirits you control gain double
strike and vigilance until end of turn.
My first thought here is that this is
actually a pretty good package. The
passive can be a good source of bodies
on board to block when paired with other
things. The plus one is a good source of
value and graveyard filling, and the
minus four can let the deck round the
corner and push toward victory after
it's been churning with leaving
graveyard synergies for a while.
Along with this excellent set of
abilities comes the downside that
Quintorius, History Chaser is a
planeswalker and can thus be attacked by
opposing creatures to get them off the
board for basically free.
To me, what this means is that you'd
want blockers to be able to keep
opposing creatures at bay. So, my first
instinct is that in most cases you
probably want to wait an extra turn or
two to set up synergy pieces before
casting this, rather than just slamming
it down on curve. So, how is this deck
choosing to make use out of this command
zone?
Well, as far as synergies go, there are
19 cards that recur, exile, or otherwise
remove things from the graveyard, along
with five things beyond the commander
that are payoffs for cards leaving the
graveyard. To pair with these, there are
12 cards outside the commander that help
cards get into the graveyard. Though,
seven of these are pretty insubstantial,
so I guess we could say that there are
five cards that are proper graveyard
enablers.
As an added layer of synergy, there are
some discard payoffs with currency
converter, conspiracy theorist, and
containment construct all letting the
deck accumulate extra resources off of
discarded cards in some form or other.
And these compare nicely with the
commander.
As a final bit of cohesion, the deck has
19 creatures that are spirits, five
other cards beyond the commander that
create spirit tokens, and another few
cards that synergize with spirits in
some other way.
Between this wide-ranging synergy core,
moderate counts of draw and ramp, and a
nice though somewhat narrow span of
cards to interact with opposing plays,
this deck is looking to out-grind
opponents and assemble an army of
spirits before swinging in big. So,
that's the plan. But, how is this plan
likely to work out in practice? To start
with some things I like about this deck,
there are a lot of cool game plan
elements that work together pretty
cohesively. Leaving graveyard payoffs
paired with an assortment of different
recursion effects make for a satisfying
pairing where you're being rewarded for
doing things that already feel good to
do.
I also think the scale of this deck's
plan for winning makes a lot of sense.
You've got a commander that can turn out
a lot of tokens and who can also make
those tokens hit like a truck with his
minus four, and this is paired with a
generally grindy game plan and some
number of creature buffing effects. I
even had some luck getting engines to
come together in decent time when I was
doing my test games with this precon.
The average synergy core the deck had
put together by the end of turn five was
actually better than it was for the
blight curse precon I reviewed a couple
months ago, even if the number of total
dud games was a bit higher here. So,
where do the problems of this deck I was
mentioning come from?
Fundamentally, there are a few issues
with the way this deck functions, and
the biggest one is that it puts a lot of
pressure on its planeswalker commander
to stick around on board. As I said
earlier, there are five cards in the 99
I'd consider decent or good options for
getting cards in the graveyard, with a
handful of others that offer a weaker
version of this. And what that means is
that the commander is going to be doing
a lot of heavy lifting to keep the
deck's graveyard stocked. This feature
of the deck is compounded by its options
for value generation, which largely
don't come online that early in the
game. Seven of the 12 options I've
categorized under value cost five or
more mana, require some sort of setup,
or more or less require that the
commander stick around in play.
The remaining options aren't even that
amazing, containing things like Fateful
Tempest that gives opponents more agency
over our fate than I'd like, as well as
Lelia, who needs to be attacking and
therefore not blocking in order to
generate value. This is relevant because
the commander is a planeswalker, a card
that opponents can attack with their
creatures to kill as long as they can
get around blockers. Planeswalkers are
much better in 20 health 1v1 formats
because there's only one opponent you
need to worry about swinging in, and the
lower life total means that a
planeswalker soaking up a bit of damage
can be genuinely helpful in its own
right. In Commander, though, the massive
life totals mean that attacking
opponents often feels barely useful
anyway in the earlier stages of the
game, but attacking a planeswalker can
mean eliminating an opposing threat
without needing to spend a card. I've
also been in a lot of situations where
an opponent will use a removal spell on
a chunky creature I have in play to
block for my planeswalker, which then
ends up making that removal spell a
two-for-one since it lets my opponents
collectively thwack my planeswalker to
death as well. Now, all of this doesn't
mean that planeswalkers are totally
unusable in EDH, or even that a
planeswalker commander is a bad choice.
This version of Quintorius is much more
powerful than the previous creature
iterations if you can keep him around on
board, and I could imagine a universe in
which you wait to play Quintorius until
you have some tools to keep him around,
or at least until you're able to get a
couple spirits off him the same turn to
block with. The problem is this deck
isn't designed to do that. It usually
feels clunky and awkward without the
commander. It's graveyard filling
options too sparse, and its value
engine's too techy and conditional. If
I'm packing a handful of payoff, I'm
going to be wanting to run out this bad
boy as soon as possible, and that could
mean putting him in a very precarious
position on board.
This feature of the deck is worsened by
its mana base, which is honestly the
most disappointing precon mana base I
reviewed since the first one I reviewed,
Blame Game.
Despite my best efforts, five of my 20
test games with this deck saw a missed
early land drop. And part of the issue
here is the raw count of 37. This can be
a perfectly fine number of lands to run
if you've got a decent amount of early
draw, filtering, or land cycling that
can dig you to more. But this deck
doesn't really have any of these things.
I honestly don't understand why we're
still getting pre-cons with fewer than
39 lands in an era with ample quality
MDFCs and utility lands that can be
added to decks. It seems like we're just
dooming newer players to have
unnecessary mana screw games.
Beyond the raw count, the mana base is
also awkward in some other ways. Its
symbol counts are high due to running a
very high number of tapped duals, but
this also means some extra clunkiness in
the early game. And there are some
baffling inclusions like Mistveil
Plains, Study Hall, and Lotus Field that
add to the awkwardness.
The end effect of all of this is making
the commander's filtering feel even more
essential for smoothing and finding land
drops. And I have to imagine this will
play out poorly in practice a lot of
games. For my test games, I used the
rule that Quintorius would survive the
turn cycle as long as I had one blocker
for each turn past three. But honestly,
I'm pretty sure that testing policy is
not nearly conservative enough to
account for what a harsh environment an
EDH game is for planeswalkers, even at
bracket two.
Beyond the issue of over-reliance on the
commander, there are a couple other
things this deck has going against it in
my eyes. One of these is an issue that
sort of compounds on that last one, a
vulnerability to graveyard hate. In
theory, effects that exile your
graveyard shouldn't be the end of the
world for this deck since it's looking
for more of an incremental graveyard
plan rather than one that builds up a
massive yard full of stuff.
However, what makes it a potential issue
here is, once again, the lack of
non-commander ways to get stuff into the
yard. I can easily imagine Quintorius
creeping up in command packs over time.
And though he's pretty quick at creating
a graveyard with enough fodder to last a
while, if somebody exiles your
graveyard, you're right back to square
one.
This deck broadly seems designed to be
grindy and increase in power over the
course of a game, but graveyard hate
will also increase in frequency over the
game as opponents are able to access
more of their libraries. And without
enough ways to feed the graveyard, I can
see the late game being a bit awkward
for this deck as well. The final issue I
see here is with interaction. Some of
what's here I don't mind. All three of
the five-mana board wipes seem pretty
sweet, and there are other cards like
Skyclave Apparition and Lorehold Charm
that seem likewise well situated.
However, the overall amount here does
not impress me, particularly for a deck
that's grindy and might take a bit to
get going. I've categorized 11 cards
here as interaction, but that's probably
a bit generous given that three of the
cards included in that group are Kami of
Ancient Law, White Orchid Phantom, and
Remorseful Cleric, filler spirits with
somewhat mediocre attached interactive
tools. These seem significantly more
likely to be chump blockers for
Contorious than cards actually used
against what opponents are doing, which
is fine, but I feel like I'd honestly
rather just have a Wall of Omens at that
point. Overall, this interaction issue
will likely be felt in this deck
struggling to slow opponents long enough
to get its own plan up and running.
Though, I will say that an improvement
to the deck's card economy could help
quite a bit with this all on its own.
All right, so these are the issues I see
here. Too reliant on the commander for
draw and graveyard filling, a bit
vulnerable to graveyard hate, and
containing not enough interaction. So,
how do we go about fixing these things?
Well, weakness to graveyard hate is tied
in with the deck's graveyard feeding and
quantity of available interaction is
tied into the deck's card economy, so
we're really going to be focused on
these first two. Let's start with cuts.
This deck has some kind of filler two
and three cost creatures, and while I
see the desire to have blockers, I just
can't get fully on board with these.
Kami of Ancient Law and White Orchid
Phantom are some two-drop spirits I
mentioned earlier and don't really care
for. If you're going to have a phantom
in your deck, you could at least have
the decency to pair it with an
indestructible land and try to convince
me it's ramp. Another cut is Nacta Moon
Lore Spinner. This is probably going to
be a very cool piece of tech in eternal
formats, but in a grindy EDH deck with a
value engine commander, it feels out of
place. Another cut is going to be
Drumbellower. This is likewise far from
a bad card, but it feels pretty
under-utilized here given that the
commander's minus four already offers
vigilance on any turn you'd want to be
swinging wide.
Moving along to higher cost creatures,
I'm cutting the two Neon Dynasty
Dragons. These are also perfectly fine
cards, but they kind of just seem like
blockers here, and I'm not particularly
sold on their beat down potential with
Quintorius's minus four, either.
This deck is stacked with powerful five
drops, so I'm also cutting Karmic Guide
and Balefire Liege. The former is a
passable recursion spell, and the latter
is a guy that buffs the board, but
doesn't do a whole lot else. Finally, as
non-creature cuts, we're axing Fateful
Tempest and Monologue Tax. The latter is
kind of a poor ramp spell in general,
IMHO, and though I see the appeals of
Fateful Tempest, I dislike its
unreliability. And I also wanted to cut
a non-creature spell to avoid having our
creature count dip too low. Now for the
additions, 10 cards that each cost $3 or
less. To start with, I want to see a
couple MDFCs in here to make sure we're
hitting our land drops. Which Enchanter
is a no-brainer for a deck that doesn't
have a whole ton of non-creature
permanent removal at the moment, and
Makindi Stampede feels nice as a way to
replace the spirit buffing of Balefire
Liege. Next up, let's get a whole bunch
more draw and filtering in here. From
the main set, I'm pulling Arc of Hunger.
Cool ass card name and art, by the way.
And Pursue the Past, both of which help
fill our graveyard and generate card
advantage. Something I've been noticing
more and more is Wizards of the Coast
including fairly obvious additions to
precons within the main set, which seems
nice as a way to get newer players
started in tuning their decks. Another
filtering spell I'm adding is Fear of
Missing Out, which is a next blocker
that can offer some crazy alpha strike
potential with Quint's minus four later
in the game, since that loyalty ability
also gives vigilance.
Tursa Lightshaper is another addition
with a similar profile, an immediate
burst of filtering, a blocker in the
short term, and a value engine once your
graveyard hits threshold. Brass's Tunnel
Glider also fits this mold, not
including a body to block with, but
being an even better filtering tool and
an even better value engine later in the
game. As a sixth and final filtering
inclusion, we're adding good old Plargg.
I love that we get to include the
Lorehold flip dean from the previous
Strixhaven set. And a two-drop creature
who can tap to rummage is exactly what
this deck is looking for.
All right. Now that we've eaten our
vegetables with these first eight, I
have two more fun additions. On Wings of
Gold is an enchantment printed in the
Ethersworn Zombie precon, and its
appeals are simple. It's an extra
leaving graveyard payoff, and possibly
more importantly, it gives our spirits
plus one plus one and flying, further
improving this deck's ability to punch
in for damage. For our final inclusion,
I'm adding the flip card Mila and Lukka.
The front side is a nice fox friend to
help defend Quintorius, and the back
side is a top-end planeswalker that
plays nicely into the deck's graveyard
themes. All right. Those are my 10 cuts
and additions. Overall, this precon is
operating in some fun mechanical
territory, and this style of red white
deck is really unique and deserves to be
seen more.
It does also feel pretty Lorehold to me,
and I like that we still manage to get a
few new arts for cards even in a set
with five precons.
Also, with this set, we finally finished
the Tango and Bicycle Land cycles after
11 and nine years, respectively. Budget
typed dual land enjoyers, rejoice. So,
broadly, I don't mind this precon, or
even the fact that it has some issues
that make it a bit sub-optimal.
That said, I would prefer that precons
steer away from the sorts of issues that
make it likely for them to stall out.
Not enough lands, over-reliance on the
commander, and especially not enough
filtering. What I mean by filtering is
cards that prioritize letting you see
more of your library over value or
increasing your total card pool. This
phrase accurately describes five of my
10 additions, even if four of those are
also capable of being value positive,
and the appeal of these in something
like a precon is very straightforward.
Seeing more of your deck is good. Seeing
more of your deck lets you play more of
your deck, put together more interesting
combinations of cards from your deck,
and if nothing else, lay your eyes on
and hold within your fingers a greater
proportion of the cardboard that exists
within your deck. That is going to be
enjoyable for most decks, but it's
especially important for precon's.
Imbuing players with a sense of agency
should be the number one goal here, and
that's what friends like Plarg are here
for.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to
Archidekt for supporting the channel.
Archidekt's multi-layered category
system makes it easy for me to dig into
decks like I did here, and the maybe
board category system is great for
displaying something like additions and
cuts. A link to my upgrade of this
precon is in the description.
Also, if you're in the market for
high-quality sleeves with a great
variety of different colors and designs,
you can pick yourself up some Dragon
Shield sleeves at my affiliate link in
the description using code Salubrious
for 5% off. If you want to support me
more directly, you can sign up for my
Patreon or sign up for a YouTube
membership. Those lovely people get
bonus videos from me once a month or so,
and some of them get to be featured in
my credits as well. Don't you want to
see your name on screen?